all right
all right what's up everybody
how's it going happy halloween to y'all
i hope you guys are having a fantastic
halloween so far if you're celebrating
halloween i know a lot of you guys for
uh
out of country you know but in uh here
in the u.s
it's halloween and it's one of my
favorite times of the year
it's a spooky time you know it's a super
scary time it's a good excuse to dress
up
um you know i pulled together what i
could which was basically just
this shirt right here all right um if if
you don't know who i am
you know i've heard a lot of comments
that i look like one particular
video game character so i was like you
know what i'm just gonna grab what i got
in my closet and put this on that's
right i am i'm joseph seed from far cry
um i've heard it enough you know i've
heard enough comments about it so i was
like you know screw
it let's just let's just go for it um
but if you guys are just joining me
today and if you're watching this video
when it's not live well here's what
we're doing
i'm running this render contest it's
called parallel dimensions
and we got uh we're putting together a
little environment
something like this this is what i
created on the very first
stream this is a and this is a master
class
in creating environments in 3d so this
is some concept art that i put together
with you guys on the first stream in
volume one we're on volume four
and for volume four what we're doing
today
we're putting together um all of our
foreground stuff so we have our swamp we
did our swamp
in um volume two and we
in volume three we did the volcano and
today we're doing the huts
we're doing the trees in the foreground
we're going to do
the trees in the mid ground we're going
to do the huts on the left side here
and we're going to add a little bit more
detail you know to our foreground with
some stumps and whatnot
and maybe some shrubbery and some
general brush
going on so that's that is the plan
for today is to add a bit more detail
and actually tell a story with our
environment
to tell a story with our foreground um
and really you want to tell a story
throughout the whole thing
but you want to be thinking like what is
the story in the piece of art that
you're creating i think art is always
better when it's when
there's story involved even if it's just
a picture
um there's there's more depth added to
the whole thing
and your mind actually goes off and
starts coming up with different
characters different ideas
so that's our goal today is to fill out
the foreground with a bunch of detail
in order to tell a story of what the
heck is going on here
and that could be up to everybody you
know whatever you guys
want to you know want to feel like the
story tells here
um so
man there's there's a lot there's a lot
to talk about i took notes there's so
much to talk about i took
notes okay so
if you guys don't know what the heck is
going on here we're again we're doing an
environment contest
and it's actually sponsored by pny and
nvidia they reached out and they're like
hey we want to give out some awesome
prizes
um so there's some really cool stuff you
guys can win like
the first place prize is a uh quadro rtx
4000
graphics card and they sent me a quadro
and i'm i'm loving it i'm absolutely
loving it and allows me to do larger
scenes like this so
super cool but the idea here is to
basically if you go to the landing page
which
there's a link in the description the
pny landing page
you basically um you know
the idea is to download a template file
which looks something like
this right here okay
and you're supposed to fill out the
environment however you like and i'm
going to choose the top 20 submissions
and put them together into an awesome
audio visual render montage with some
cool music
and um you know of those 20 i will
choose the top
three now us prizes you can only win
prizes if you're in the u.s
um but that's totally okay because if
you
win as well and you're international i'm
going to be sending you guys some of my
professional photography art prints
um if you guys know i'm a photographer i
shoot film and digital
and i have a print store it's called
noise green and light.com there's a link
in the description below as well
um so yeah i just want to make it worth
you guys as well
but really at the end of the day we're
here to learn and make something awesome
together
okay so let's let's take a look at these
notes here how are you guys doing
it's been a week since we've been
hanging out is everyone doing okay
thumbs up if you're excited for
halloween if you're excited for this
stream
or just give me a thumbs up if you're
watching and having a good time
so let's see
yeah i'm excited to jump into this it's
going to be it's going to be a good one
we got nathan graham davis in the house
awesome writer a couple streams ago i
did a vfx shot for nathan for his uh
his writing uh series that he's got
going on where he's gonna write a whole
feature and he's gonna guide you guys
through the process it's basically like
what this is
but for writing um he's doing one every
week
so shout outs to nathan arne thanks for
the super chat i appreciate you
have i had renon you want to hear his
norwegian
i don't know what that is but
um oh he speaks norwegian maybe
maybe he does um i have not had ren on
but
i really want to i really really want to
um he lives close by so maybe we can get
rent on at some point
yeah yeah what's up apex
you are a blender artist but you're
still gonna learn yes that's the whole
point guys it doesn't matter what
program you use the idea is that you can
take all of these concepts
and ideas and apply them to your own
program and i think you actually
get a little bit better you level up a
little bit more when you do that because
you figured out for yourself
and really the only way to learn is by
doing that's not the only way but it's
the best way
learn by doing so that's the whole point
of us meeting here on saturday
is to spend time creating some awesome
stuff together
awesome awesome to see you guys in the
chat here yeah it's been it's been a
good week
the corridor guys have been in texas
shooting but we've been back working on
a bird democ
remaking the the vfx of birdemic which
is insane
absolutely insane
um all right so this is going to be an
exciting stream a very very interesting
stream i'm going to do something i've
never
done before
which is you know if you guys if you
guys don't know
so this stream specifically today is
sponsored
by parsec and parsec is
a remote desktop application that allows
you to remote in
to you know your maybe your work
computer so right now like
my corridor computer is you know 30
minutes away
in downtown los angeles right and
if i need to get on that computer
instead of driving all the way down
there
i can just parsec in so it's really cool
though because they actually reached out
to me
after i've been using their software in
their program
um so it was is awesome it's a really
cool service let me just show you guys
real quick
and i'm gonna be using parsec on today's
stream to be able to hop into my work
computer to grab files and bring them
back
um over here today so let me just pull
this up for y'all
yeah i love their ui i love their their
whole experience
now you can actually get it for free but
they do offer a 10 a month
you actually save 20 20 if you sign up
for a year
and it's called parsec warp and the idea
with warp is like
you get uh dual monitor support so you
can do two monitors
it actually has like a legit um
like 444 color mode so you're actually
able to
get the truest amount of color with your
monitor right
and also it's set up for the tablet
which you guys know i'm on a tablet all
the time
so it has pressure sensitivity and tilt
support and all that good stuff
it's an amazing service so i got some
files
that are on my work computer that i need
to get onto
my home computer right here okay
so i just want to show you guys how easy
this is and christian hey thanks for the
super chat
appreciate you man um it's gonna be
exciting it's gonna be a good one
so really all i have to do these are all
the different computers that you know as
long as you're logged into your parsec
account
um you can hop in to any computer
so this is my work computer
boom and i'm into my work computer it's
as easy as that
super low it's basically zero latency
you're in here
um and you'll forget that you're
on another computer it's that easy
and it works that well so like i said
you get the
the double monitor situation going um
let's see so you go here and you grab
your second screen and you can just pop
this over obviously you guys you don't
see my second screen because
you know i'm only streaming one screen
but you got access to that
um and then your your prefer 444 color
boom you just want to check that on and
it'll
it'll update so you're getting the
purest
color quality so it's pixel per pixel
color um
and uh yeah so here's what we're going
to do let's go full screen
on this so we're in and i want to pull
out a couple
models here so i'm in cinema 4d on my
work computer so if you were at
corridor right now you'd see my computer
like ghosting on like this
which is super cool so i have these like
huts
right and originally you know i had
these mongolian yurts
that i was going for in the concept art
but the more
i researched it the more i realized if
you lived in a swamp
the water level is going to rise and
lower depending on the time of year
depending on the rainfall
so you'd probably be living in something
like
this where you know
you have the ability to still stay dry
because your house is lifted off the
ground so i grabbed a couple
different uh a couple different models
here
let me see let me pull up um
here we go
so we got this guy a little tiny hut
we got this guy here it's a little bit
bigger right
and these are these are pretty high
quality you know they come in different
levels of detail so
we only need it for like a medium shot a
wide shot and they'll be off in the
distance
and then you have like this guy here
which is like the main kind of structure
so i'm going to be pulling these four
from
my work computer onto
my home computer because i'm parsecked
in to my work computer right now
so i'll grab these four they're on my
desktop right here so i want to make
sure
they are in um
[Music]
the vfx folder here
so i'll pull this over grab my
second screen in parsec pop it over to
the right and just make sure that these
files
are in the vfx materials grab this over
boom
so now let's see
let's go windowed here
close this if i
disconnect right
back on my home computer i will have
access
in vfx materials
to this swamp here the reed hut
swamp so i'm going to go ahead and drag
these guys in
open them up maybe i need to relink some
textures but basically you just thought
i was able to go into my work computer
and come back into cinema 4d on my
personal computer
and grab some files with parsec warp
it is the best i love it so much
so smooth yeah um
so the models yeah i got these from
turbosquid these are some turbosquid
models they're like 10 bucks a piece 15
bucks a piece
and i thought they actually worked
perfect for this thing so let me go
ahead and
and drop these guys in and then we're
going to go back we're going to parsec
back into the work computer
and grab some mega scans models come
back in
we're gonna be going back and forth
throughout the entire stream because i
really want to show you guys how awesome
this this software is
you know parsec is just super seamless
and i learned about it actually from
andre lebron
and uh i mean that dude's just a beast
you know he uses parsec he loves parsec
i just love their ui it's a good time
all right so let's go ahead and um let's
render our scene and see
what the heck we got and we'll bring
these huts in
and see if we can't get like a general
placement
of everything here
so it's doing its thing loading
we got quite a few things going on i'm
probably going to hide some stuff
because we really don't need to see the
background i just want to see my
foreground
boom looking awesome
and once we get our foreground looking
nice i'm probably going to go in
and add a bit of sky uh
to this guy here as well wind bush
what's up dude
what is going on happy halloween to you
wimbush
heck yeah dude we're doing a 3d
environment
building this thing out
all right so let's go ahead
and bring in these
models i'm gonna go ahead and merge the
projects
here we go a ton of folders i'm doing a
video on folder management later this
year probably a christmas
um it'll be a christmas video
because we got to be able to access our
files as quickly as possible
here we go boom
so i'll hop out of camera view pause my
my render there and we'll just bring
these guys in and make sure they're
looking nice
so that size is about correct
it berrien i don't know if i said that
right
uh thanks for the super chat man i
appreciate you very very much
just want to say i'm inspired by your
work uh with c4d i'm rendering right now
as i type this so my cpu is screaming do
you have any advice for someone looking
uh for work in the vfx industry
man so if you guys are trying to get
work in the vfx industry
i think the first place to start at
least i can only speak about
my experience and i
got started as a freelancer so i started
doing freelance work
for friends and just really nurturing
those relationships and making sure that
those relationships are as solid as
possible
because really when you're doing
business with someone it comes down to
the relationship right so
the more work you do for that person
they'll come back to you with other work
and you'll
they'll you know tell other people about
you and it'll just kind of grow
over time word of mouth that hey this
guy rocks he does good work
and you'll keep getting freelance jobs
and then you'll eventually get to a
point where you can put to put a reel
together
now if you want to fast track that reel
you can also do some vfx for yourself
make your own videos which is totally
what i did um
early youtube you know i started doing
stuff like carbon warfare carbon warfare
2 the killzone video
and if i wanted to you know if i wanted
to get into a vfx house i could just
package all the stuff that i put
together maybe some stuff i did for
clients
package together into a real and maybe
you send that around and it's all just
word of mouth and
relationships so you know you'll get
into certain studios do i
apply to certain studios and they'll see
your work and be like yo this guy does
good work
it all comes down to the work you are
only as good
well that's not true when you're getting
hired at a vfx place
they look at your work first and then
they're like the second thing is hey is
this guy cool can i
talk with this person um you know
are they nice and then that'll get you
in so just keep it up
also persistence you got to stay stay
focused
and keep at it that's really the main
thing is to keep at it
so we can see here the materials are not
they're not synced up so i'm going to
just going to merge the rest of these
and then we'll sync the materials at the
end
so bring in these huts
obviously this one's too tiny
and i'm really just judging this off of
the doorway
let's see where are you
so that's why i have a person in every
scene or if this person wasn't here
rather
i'd be making a person figure
and scaling it up so that you know
they'd fit through this little door
right there
they're probably about the same size
these two
all right let's do
[Music]
the others
this one's super tiny as well definitely
scale that guy up
and you just want to get the opening
about right
that feels good and lastly
our last guy here
and we're gathering all of our materials
so that we can place these in a really
unique way
and this is just the prep you got to do
before you bring this stuff
in so i think that's about good size
wise on that one
so we got like four huts here that i
think will be really really cool
to place into our scene they're going to
take the place of these yurts that you
guys are seeing
here
nice okay so yeah winbush says that you
started as an intern and worked your way
up you made a lot of good contacts that
way as well
absolutely yeah like i said i can only
speak to my experience so
it's cool that windbush you have a
second you know a different
side of that you know a different way to
get into the industry so
everyone's got their story um and their
way of doing things
i think it's super awesome so yeah
definitely like if you guys can intern
at a place
that's that might be an even better
route
you know as long as you're doing vfx and
you're
in the place where you want to be that's
that's the best combo
all right so i'm saving out iterations
here because i want to make sure that
i have different versions of my project
file i don't want to
lose any sort of data
all right let's go ahead and re-link
these
textures here okay
so the best way to do this
for some reason the the re-linking
method the battery relinking in cinema
it doesn't really work for me so i got
to do this thing by hand
[Music]
so this is hut 001
we're going for logs base color
2. cool and luckily
the path directory stays the same
and this is uh
the same deal but now we're looking for
the wood dark wood
texture there it is
and you're just quickly going through
all this making sure
that you don't go too fast and screw
things up obviously
octane crashed it looks like
see if it can revive itself usually when
it crashes here it's it's done for
but we'll re-link these textures and
then we'll parsec back in and grab some
mega scans assets
um we'll favorite some and then we'll
download them here on our end
it's just a way to to show you guys how
easy it is to parsec in
so let's keep going this is
one roof base color and the thing is
actually i can even do this faster you
don't have
to even select the right one because the
file name has the right name all you
have to do is open it
or just hit enter and it's going to know
exactly
the right one
this is just the process guys this is
how it goes
so this is o4
and just the note i've always been
saying this but if you guys have any
black and white material textures here
make sure that those are set to float
it's going to save you a lot of vram um
in the long run especially when your
scene is built out and it's pretty huge
you definitely definitely want to make
sure that you're saving as much memory
as possible
this one's o6
and same deal here
awesome okay so i'm saving the scene um
i'm going to restart cinema while we
parsec back into our work computer
and gather some some mega scans textures
and assets
so this this should be good we'll place
these when we come back
so i'm going to go ahead and close this
[Music]
yes please
all right we'll restart cinema
and i'm going to parsec back into my
work computer
and open up bridge and let's favorite
some assets here so we can actually
um you know pull them back on the main
computer
but i want to show you guys how easy
this really is now this might be pulled
up on the second screen
so what's the hotkey control shift oh
wait
oh no there it is
all right all right so
if i look here there's some there's some
swampy tree stumps
and there's some you know some
dilapidated old trees here in the
background
so i'm definitely going to want to grab
some broken down trees
some you know scraggly branches here
and some stumps that's gonna be my first
first little bit here eric yo thank you
for the super chat happy halloween to
you
eric um not even a message you don't
even have a message you're just like yo
here you go man i appreciate you thank
you
bradley okay so he said if you press
window asset
inspector you can re-link all the
textures at once
um interesting interesting okay so let
me
let me go back in here um
make sure cinema's opening on my end
awesome
i'll check that out in a minute
sotomante okay so sodamonte is our
moderator
here in the chat as well as the uh the
discord server
for all this learning that we're doing
together uh he says clint
what percent of the project do you think
you have done
um i'm probably 60 of the way finished
on mine
also guys i forgot to mention
i totally forgot to mention a couple
things
so first um
let me get all this crap out of the way
parsec back in
all right um so
i completely forgot to mention that the
due date
for the parallel dimensions submission
process
it got extended originally it was
supposed to be like
midnight november 1st basically november
2nd um which is on monday
but it got extended to november 6th so
if you guys are working on this
um on this contest with me and you're
putting together
you know your awesome environment you
have until november
6th okay if you go to the link in the
description it's the p and y
landing page if you scroll all the way
down you'll see a timer counting down to
you know the final submission it got
updated all right so you have more time
take the time to make your render
awesome also
there's a hundred megabyte limit on
the the file you can upload so if you're
if your render
is too large you also need to include
your project file
if it's too large then what you can do
is upload it to google drive
and then just upload like a readme file
with the links
to the download to your render and your
project file
on the pny landing page so you can kind
of cheat it a little bit get around it
um but yeah no that's that's big news
big news you guys have an extension on
the timetable here that's because
originally i said it was the sixth and
then it kind of went back to the second
so i was like eh screw it
it's going to be the sixth all right
i've been learning a lot
throughout the process all right so i'm
parsect into my
work computer at corridor and i'm gonna
just
favorite some assets here um
for our foreground okay and mega scans
is basically the best thing ever
um you know they got a lot of good stuff
here they're constantly updating all
their all their stuff
their assets but we want trees so i'm
just going to type in
tree and we'll go to
3d assets
and we'll just scroll down and see what
we got here um
they have some really good like
complete tree stumps like oh this stuff
is good okay this thai beach branch
i'm a favorite that so i'm gonna just go
through and favorite the ones that i
think
will really help us here here is a great
one this tree stump super classic
the reason i'm not going for any of
these other ones is because they're cut
off at the top
i want the full deal you see how this is
connected
so i'm going to favorite that one i'm
going to keep going down here here's
another example of something that could
totally work for us
um this one could too but it's a little
it's a little much you know i don't know
not a little much it's a little little
it's not enough
this one's cool this mossy log i like
that
and you can always unfavorite stuff you
know you can't go too far
this one's good this one's totally
awesome
um this one's fine this one's great
and basically you know i'm going for
you know this kind of vibe here the more
branches that come off of these the
better
um this guy's great this kind of stuff
you know so i'm looking for some big
tree stumps with some with a large base
to it
and a lot of uh like offshoots a lot of
dead offshoots
as well as these trees back here i know
they have like three trees
like full trees but they're dead which
is exactly what we want
like this right here this dead tree boom
we want that
absolutely this granite rock assembly
why not that's pretty sweet
here's a free asset broken stump
uh here we go this is like all your
craggly branches and stuff
i dig all that
here is a fallen tree i'm gonna i'm
gonna get that
i'm gonna get that
here's another broken tree another burnt
tree
another fallen tree like this is all
really good stuff
the dead branches pack yes please
oh look at that dead tree that thing is
perfect
another perfect dead tree there
and that might just do it um
[Music]
i want to make sure i didn't miss
anything though this is pretty sweet
this dry root
they just have so much stuff this is a
cool tree stump i like that broken
branch that's nice
and that's it so that's everything you
type in tree on mega scans and they got
it all fantastic
and if you guys forgot yes i am
parsecked in
to my weird computer but it's so
seamless
i legit forget that i'm in my work
computer
um yeah anything else you guys said
maybe some rocks
um oh what's up casey
yo casey edward's in the house
shout out to casey edwards happy
halloween to you man hope to see you
tonight
be a good time i hope you enjoy your
walk casey isn't
is an amazing composer i've worked with
him for
a very long time now i think the dead
island video i did on this channel was
the first video i did with casey
um and he kills it man it just freaking
kills it i will be working with you
for as long as i can hopefully until
we're both like 90 years old eating
extra sharp cheddar cheese out of our
coat pockets
it'll be a good time matthew mills up in
here what's up
heck yeah all right so
we favored some assets let's hop out of
parsec
and we're back into my actual work
computer here
i love how seamless that is super
helpful
it literally saved us during this
pandemic so we were able to parsec into
our work computers and like knock stuff
out while we're at home
it really is a game changer they also
have a teams version as well
where you can do like better work as
teams together
through parsec and it's got a lot of
like
privacy features and stuff and allows
people to to access different computers
in the network so i can
access any any different person's
computer in the studio
so if you need to grab a file or
something you can do it super easy
but okay yeah let's uh let's get this
going so we have our huts
and let's open up mega scans on
my home computer
we can see we're going to download these
if we go to favorites you can see
that everything here is favorited over i
believe that is that everything
i feel like we're missing some 3d assets
here we go yeah this is everything
so some of these already have like this
this tree but i'm going to download some
of these ones that i don't have
and make sure my download settings are
correct so
you definitely want to download the 8k
version but you can export a lower
quality version
i'm going to grab some of these
other level of details here because i
don't need like the fullest detail if
it's going to be off in the background
and we can go to global download
settings and bridge to make sure that
that's the case that's all
transferred over so let's go and
download that
we'll download these guys hopefully it
doesn't wreck the stream
but we'll see
all right that should do it
sweet
so what are we building anyone who's
just joining
we are creating out this environment
here this is concept art that i created
in uh volume one of the environment
master class about three weeks ago
and we are basing our render off of this
concept art that we created
in volume two of the master class we
focused on the ground plane
in volume 3 which was last week we
focused on the volcano
and this week we're focusing on the
foreground and adding detail in our
foreground
so let's go back into cinema let's
render
and see what we can see
uh
all right
sweet
so it looks like we just need to relink
this last
texture
it might be the normal that didn't come
through
what's going on here time to do some
problem solving
now it looks like maybe i need to reload
octane
what is going on here
so i'll try soloing it
and it looks like there's an issue with
this material
all right so we just got to load these
guys it looks like hut 01
so we'll go in
and grab those materials
super easy
and again i got these from turbo squid
they were like 10 15 bucks each
really nice models here they all come in
different levels of detail
boom all right
awesome so we got our huts um let's go
ahead and adjust
we're gonna we're gonna adjust some
color here but let's place these huts
and then we'll download those mega scans
assets and make sure they work correctly
so let's hop in to our actual camera
view and see
what we can see here
and again we're going for this look here
with some buildings on the right and
some buildings on the
left all right
so let's see what we can do
so one thing actually we can do that
help us place things is we can actually
go into option and uncheck the check
camera option which is super confusing
um and hop out of camera and we're
actually able to
you know move things around our scene
and it'll appear in the render view
but we you know it doesn't it that's not
a one-to-one
uh recreation of what we're seeing in
the viewport so that helps move things
around we get a better angle on all this
stuff
now this big building i'm thinking can
be like
again if we're going for this you have a
building in the foreground
a building in the mid ground or kind of
background
of these three at least and then there's
like this one here which is a bigger one
so we can have kind of like a steeple
effect
going with our buildings you just want
to clearly define
the the silhouette of this stuff when
you're placing objects you want to see
what the heck it is
if you can't tell what it is then it's
kind of pointless why is it in the scene
so we want to orient the objects in a
way
that best describes that object okay
now one thing i'm going to do to help us
with the render
is i'm just going to i'm going to lose
the fog here
let's see we can lose
where would you be geometry
and fog we'll lose the fog it's going to
help speed up our render
we can also lose the smoke cards as well
that we created
last week
yeah marius you just watched the
halloween vfx arts react
that's great that's fantastic man i
thought it turned out really good
i watched the thing again after uh after
doing that episode and it was so good
so good all right enough enough chit
chat but you know honestly let's be
honest that's the whole point of this
we're just chit chatting the whole time
let's play some huts all right
get them laid out here so we can like
see what these things look like i'm
going to get rid of the mountain
just for a second because
where are you background mountain
just so i can see a little bit easier
what we're working with here
and then we'll put lights inside of
these huts too
very nice very very nice
so let's orient these things around and
find the best looking
angle for these things so i mean
definitely like a three-quarter angle is
going to be nicest
it's a matter of like you know what side
looks the best
i can open this up a little bit more
like i love that crisscross pattern here
on the roof i think that looks really
nice maybe we grab this little tiny hut
right here
and we bring this guy into the
foreground
so that'll kind of take the place of
this yurt here
and we'll orient this so that the the
light is just coming out like that
awesome and we have
this background guy
which might be
like this dude right here
and this guy could actually be up on
like a pile of rocks or something
or we could just make it taller just
straight up make it taller
but you see what i'm saying about the
silhouette you know like i want to get
the silhouette of this guy in the
foreground looking nice
um and i
want to be able to see this guy i want
to see all three of these clearly
so i'm positioning them in a way that
that's possible
so you can see this one has like an
overhang but you're not seeing it
because of this guy in the background so
we need to move that
maybe down a little bit or something
and then this big house can maybe come
up a little bit
and he scaled up and the foreground guy
can come forward so that we see its
silhouette a bit better
and we'll bring our mountain back in
because that's also very telling as well
we don't want to block too much of that
now you can see how we lose this guy a
little bit
into that mountain but i think that's
going to be okay because
the um
the fog is going to help break that up
so maybe if i bring the fog back in to
just give you an example
the fog is basically like a gradient
that separates and it adds depth
so we can see here that this this little
hut stands out a little bit more
we still have some adjustments to make
with the fog i'm not loving it right now
but at least it's in there and it's
going to help us break that up so
i'll hide the fog again because we move
a little faster with it
but again going after our reference you
can see how the fog really makes this
guy
stand out so
i want to make sure that
they don't come too far into the center
of the frame
it looks like it's split into thirds and
this guy's creeping in a little close
so i might just take all this and push
it back a little bit
something like that and i'm going to add
i think some ground
and dirt that it's sitting on versus the
water right here
and let's see
[Music]
if we go to the final frame
does that update okay it doesn't update
but we're not going too far i just want
to make sure that
that doesn't get cut off too much but i
think it's fine
liam thanks for the uh thanks for the
kind words i'm i'm really happy with how
this is turning out i think it's gonna
be really sweet
all right so this guy we can push this
guy off into the background here
because again we're going for this vibe
on the left
so these guys i'd say are in the
foreground these guys are in the mid
ground
so we'll push that back
and i'm probably going to take
this um this first hut right here
and duplicate it off onto this side too
now normally you know you know what and
actually i think to save
memory what i'm gonna do
is make an instance of this so with that
object selected let's go up in here
and let's make an instance
and the instance is
a a copy of this but it's not extra
geometry it's just uh it's just a nice
little
nice little copy so it saves us
saves us a little bit and you can just
copy that instance around and we can
make it a multi-instance
or a render instance for now and that'll
go even faster
and we can like we can scale these up
just a little bit
oh actually they don't scale because
they are instances but i think that's
all right
we'll just move them up and down a
little bit come out the water make sure
they're rotated at different
different orientations
but you just want to get a nice
silhouette because they're kind of going
to be blocked by the fog
and you're just going to see the
silhouette on all these guys
we're going to put lights in here too so
it's going to be an added nice little
bonus
so again i want to have a hole here so
the character is moving through towards
this mountain
on the left you have some some huts
you know like this on the right you have
some too and there's just a big
kind of focus point for the character to
move towards
so yeah we're definitely going to add
lights in these but we're going to do
that
after we get them placed
i'm still not happy with the placement
on all this stuff yet but
it'll get there we just gotta keep
futzing with it
and we can also render region two so it
goes a little faster
so i'll just get that little bit so
that's updating
you
you
awesome that's starting to feel pretty
nice i think with some fog it'll look
good
um but let's move over to the right side
and let's mess with
this placement just a bit as well
so maybe that guy is on the far back and
this one is uh
this one's back here
maybe this one doesn't fit like it
definitely is the one that isn't
that doesn't have a thatched roof
and going back to the reference always
checking the reference
so yeah maybe the ground plane comes up
a little bit
you know so it's sitting a little higher
that way we're able to see a bit more of
the silhouette
what this thing actually looks like and
we can we can adjust the ground plane to
to come up to that level really easily
so that's not bad
maybe i grab this guy
over here and
copy this dude over
or maybe we replace this guy with this
guy because i like the
i really like the vibe from this one
maybe something like that and then i
don't know maybe we have a third one
let's see maybe this guy could just be
like down in here
but you see what i mean here with the
silhouette you don't want these
silhouettes to like
blend into one house you want
them to be a bit more defined even like
that is a little bit better
i'm liking that
so now all we would have to do is bring
the ground
plane up to that point so the best way
to do that
would be to copy this
over like this
i'm going to move this we'll go ahead
and rotate it just so it's not an exact
copy
you know something like that maybe
and i'm going to
let's see let's go and grab this point
and we're going to do a
soft selection so we'll enable soft
selection and the radius will come out
to like
200 maybe maybe 350
450 even um and we'll do
a bell and bring this
up so you kind of raise that mountain
just a little bit and we can do that
with
with all this different different little
points
so then we move this just back here
bring that up so it's kind of on that
on that hill
and we can keep just growing the
selection
so that it looks correct
what's up joe hey thanks for joining man
we're building out this environment
we're adding some foreground elements
trying to make it look nice so now this
material
if we check the camera we go back in
this material does not
look
right for some reason oh i guess it's
because uh
you're not getting that reflection
that looks super nice
so i want to adjust that as well
hmm
i wonder if i just went too intense with
it i could have gone too intense
so let's check back in with our bridge
downloads and make sure we have
everything going
um so it looks like oh wow how is this
geez it's going slow oh and i got all
this other stuff all right sweet
so another thing we're going to want to
pull is
some like foliage and whatnot you know
we want to pull some different uh like
pieces of grass
so let's um just to show again the power
of parsec let's parsec back in
to the work computer all right we're in
bridge
and let's look up
so now this the internet is on my second
monitor
so i'm gonna go second screen
boom here we are and we got the internet
going over here
so i'll just pull this in boom so let's
type swamp um i'll just type swamp
and see what kind of like uh
pieces of foliage we see if i come in
here like this is actually pretty nice
wow very mossy um
you know some thick grass it looks like
lots of
sticks and whatnot a bunch of sticks
that's cool it looks like matcha
matcha lake going on there sweet
here's a game a level looks like a
swampy level
so i'll pull some of this grass here
let's go in a bridge
and parsec into the work computer
remote access and let's see let's grab
some favorites here so i'm going to go
to 3d plants
and i would it be aquatic
technically submerged
i mean this is like ocean um
sure sure might be better
you know this isn't bad
[Music]
c spinach
definitely this stuff this this eel
grass i'm seeing a lot of
so maybe we'll we'll favorite that guy
we'll get some basket grass
and maybe we'll grab
this this bulrush grass okay
let's see what else we have though
that's not just aquatic all right
would it be weeds
that's something like desert weed right
there
some dead ones we need like uh
let's see
ground cover then we we're in ground
cover right we did this
wild grass
oh this is a good one this another good
one
awesome awesome
so we'll definitely want to add these to
our scene as well so i'm going to hop
out of parsec we'll disconnect
and we're back into the work computer
our downloads are almost finished
oh some mushrooms yeah we could do some
mushrooms
that sounds like a good plan i like that
let's uh let's parsec back in
and we'll grab some mushrooms we can do
3d assets
i think we just type in mushrooms
ooh like these ones yeah we'll favorite
these guys for sure
these friggin poisonous mushrooms
can we can scatter these around just a
little bit that could be fun
all right we'll hop out of parsec
disconnect back to the work computer
um yeah it's i'm loving loving parsec
um serious big shout outs to them you
know this this whole stream is sponsored
by them so i just want to show you guys
the power
of what it can truly do um i've been
using it a whole bunch
so definitely show them some love you
know there's a link to parsec right here
down in the
description check it out after the
stream open up a separate tab
um i'm i know i'm going to be using it
when i'm in georgia
for christmas i'm going to be parsecking
back into this computer right here
so i can do some cool renders while i'm
gone because i can't bring my whole
desktop to georgia you know i can just
bring a laptop
or a chromebook and parsec in with that
so
yep super fun also good for games too
you can play video games on it
alright let's hop back to the render and
see what we got
so i think i want the ground
plane to
[Music]
at least extend over here right so
we want some like swampy water going
back over on this section so i'm gonna
uncheck the check camera option we'll
hop out of here
and i'll just try duplicating this again
bringing it over and seeing
what that looks like
huh it actually looks pretty cool
so you kind of want that like drifting
off into the water
a little bit
so i'll angle it down so it kind of
sweeps off into the water
and that actually looks pretty good so
they're on
that dirty ground and then you have
you know the lake
meeting it at that point basically right
there
now i don't i don't know why i have
my lake rotated like that
i don't know if that's because i needed
to like catch the
light
now this light is reflecting
and getting us that nice yeah that nice
reflection in the foreground now for
whatever reason
this guy if i were to check the camera
back on and look at this thing
i think it's just because this light
isn't tall enough
so it's really just a matter of like
moving pieces around to shape out
your environment
but i don't i don't like that so i'm
going to undo
and really try and
hone this back in that's definitely the
best version so far
so i'll create a landscape material
and i want to get this foreground
looking correct
so i'll scale it up
move it down and we can keep scaling it
because i want these guys to be able to
sit on this thing
something like that maybe
and we could angle it i think this guy
might be a little too high
in the background here so i might try
and
fit it in
i might try and rotate this thing around
bring it down and in a little bit closer
something like that
there we go now whatever material is on
our foreground here
it's really really nice looking
so i just want to drop that
on this new landscape we just created
that actually looks that looks pretty
good to me
it's all a matter of just shaping and
moving this thing around until it looks
right
and then we can go through here and
change the seed of this
until we get something that actually
matches looks correct
and you could honestly
duplicate this
scale it down move it up
and have a second
piece for this guy to sit on because
that's really what i'm trying to do is
just ground this second hut
and you can actually go through here and
change
this to more of like a plateau so you do
the plateau level
comes up to like there so then it's
sitting on top of this
you just put this under
something like that
cool yeah that's actually that's not too
bad so let's put some lights in these
guys yeah
speedy blue seven welcome welcome to the
stream
we're making a really cool environment
and uh this is actually a contest
the submission delivery deadline is by
the sixth so you still got time you can
download the template on the pny landing
page in the description
this is the last week we're putting this
stuff together you know i'm probably
gonna do the character
um throughout the week here
because i don't have time to do that i
still need to photoscan myself
so we'll definitely need to do that but
let's go ahead and grab um
let's make some lights whoa
let's make some lights and put them
inside these huts
and point them up
bring them inside here
sit it just on the ground and we'll take
that light you can see you can see that
point light we don't want to see it so
we'll turn the visibility
to off in camera
and if we let's see if we do um
well let's change the color temperature
because we're going for fire light
we're going for natural light all this
stuff is lit by fire if you've played
the last of us too
and you've been to the island then you
know exactly what i'm going for
we're going for that natural warmth
um let's do let's lock
our render so we can move it we can even
zoom in so like 1.3 times
and i'm just gonna render this region
right here
so it renders faster and let's take that
light and turn up the power to like
300
and it looks like it's not doing much
so i'm going to cheat it i'm going to
open up that light
so like you're just getting light from
the entire floorboard
basically
and it looks like you know maybe there's
a fire going inside of this place
i think that's kind of cool we can also
do
you know something like uh
instead of it
spawning from an area or a square you
can
actually change it so it's a omni
light
for some reason that's not working
you should be able to change the uh the
shape of it
details area shape yes we'll do um
a sphere
that's absolutely massive so we'll scale
it down
and we can just move it maybe inside
here and we'll do one
over in here
and we'll take that up to like 500 each
eric yeah agreed the character's not
done that's just the template like
placeholder guy
so maybe we scale up these spheres a
little bit more
oh my god that's the power of the sun
definitely too intense
so i almost feel like the the square
was the way to go so i'm going to undo
back
to the square
because that just felt better to me and
i can even bring it off the floor just a
little bit
so you can kind of get a creepy under
lit vibe going on inside
and maybe
you bring it up like that or something
but i feel like fire light you know fire
light definitely is coming from the
ground unless you have hanging lanterns
which i could see so maybe we did more
of a hanging lantern vibe and we had
like a couple of these guys
placed throughout
like that which to me feels pretty good
we'll back them off
maybe something like that they're coming
from inside
and we're trying to bounce the light off
the ceiling
the other example would be to point them
down
to the ground and we raise these guys
up
so you get a bit of more of an even
light throughout the inside of this
thing but honestly i like the other
version when the when the lights were
pointed up it's a bit more dynamic
and we can again change the intensity of
those
so let's copy these and
move them into this other area
this other building this mid
mid ground building
i'm gonna zero out
the orientation on that that's super
bright super intense
and we can maybe have one more light
going
in this thing also another thing is we
can take
this actual building and put the lights
in the appropriate building i think
that's going to
make this process a little easier so
that's going to be
that guy
boom so now when we move the whole
building the lights will come with it
ah
so we'll check oop yeah we'll check
camera back on
we'll hop into our scene camera
and we'll uncheck it and hop back in
just kind of a reset there
that looks super cool we got some light
coming from the inside
so let's find this guy and we'll drop
those lights
in there and we'll keep we'll keep going
so i'll grab two of them and i'll move
those
into this foreground hut
i think i can just go with one
liam dude thank you for the super chat
i'm glad you enjoy the streams man
they're really fun for me so we we can
we can bring this up and
you can adjust these lights
however you want until you get the
desired effect you're going for
that's kind of creepy i like that
we can take the power up what if we took
the power up to
i don't know 9000
yeah way too intense
so this is not good here this there's a
lot of fireflies going on here
um that aren't going to help us so
we want to try
and minimize that by not pointing lights
at the ground
definitely don't want to do that
so we'll just keep it limited to the hut
itself
this is feeling cool i'm really digging
this
yeah i mean we could do lanterns
certainly we could take it to the next
level
do some lanterns which is yeah
definitely a possibility
it's all just a matter of time here
again the way i work
i try to work as general as possible
um and as large scale as possible and
then i work things in
um i work the detail
in right so with these
with these huts basically i'm lighting
the huts i'm getting the general feel of
it
and then i'll i'll go from there i'll
continue from there
to make things uh more detailed
get that looking nice
awesome you get the lights reflecting
off of the
the swampy lake i dig that
and then we'll go ahead and copy
these lights in here so we'll find this
guy
and actually you know what we can do i'm
gonna try this i'm gonna try the
transfer tool so since i have lights in
this one
this is the same model i want to just
basically copy this and move it in place
of that
so i'm going to control c control v we
have a copy of this
hut and then use the transfer tool let's
do
where would you be i already have it
pinned up here you can hit shift c
and type in transfer as well and find
the transfer tool
but i'm going to click the transfer tool
and i want it to
transfer
why are you grayed out mr transfer tool
all right it looks like it's working
and i think it just worked
i think
yep it's in here um i'm going to
[Music]
delete the hut we transferred it to
and then i think the lights just got
no the lights didn't get wigged out i
don't know why we're not
seeing the lights in our render oh
that's because the
model is hidden there it is way back
there
let's take these guys and bring the
lights
down onto the floor so we're getting the
most light throughout this little hut
that's looking really nice
i dig that and then finally we have
this last guy
so i'm just going to pop these three
lights ctrl drag
to copy them into this big one here i'm
just going to scale them up
instead of making a fourth one
and that looks really nice
that's pretty freaking sweet
so again that is from general to
specific
so we did general lighting setup
on these huts here
that's awesome that looks super cool
i think with fog it's going to look even
cooler
we have our steam our smoke cards in
here
in the back so that's adding depth to
the background
um
[Music]
i think i need to maybe work the color
the color of some of these huts i think
might be a little bit too saturated
and then certainly adding fog to this
whole thing is gonna
you know really spice this up
it's also going to slow down your render
like crazy
so definitely be prepared for that
so i know another fog trick um
one that actually saves a lot of time
i'm gonna give this a shot let's hide
the fog
and you know what let's set this up
we're gonna parsec in
to my work computer again to show you
how easy this all is
i'm gonna make a new c4d file
and i'm gonna set up something simple
for you guys so basically we have
a card like this i'm going to stand it
up
so it's uh right on 90 okay
i'm going to make a new octane material
you can do that by hitting shift c
type in octane diffuse material and
you'll find uh
there it is down there we'll open it up
and let's go ahead and apply it to this
card let's
render our scene
awesome and we'll come in here this is a
very simple setup
basically in the opacity tab i'm going
to pop out here into
a gradient
and it's as simple as that so we can
take this gradient
and actually let me do
fall off do you think falloff will do it
now um i think we were we had it with a
with a gradient an octane gradient
perhaps
it goes from one
to the other
now we had it with the original
that's it right there we just want it
the opposite so we want the fog to be on
the ground
and then disappear as we get higher up
into the sky
so 2dv but then we need to
orient the angle around so do 180.
and from here we can crunch this
and we can make the fog not as bright
and you can really take this down and
make it subtle like this
and this is uh this is a way to cheat
the fog
so what i'm gonna do is
let's see um let's go ahead
and we'll save as go to our desktop
we'll type this fast fog
all right and then i'm going to drop
this into
vfx materials folder
i'll bring up my second monitor
on parsec and i'll just drop this
into vfx
folder here vfx materials
in the root
and then i'll go i'm going to disconnect
from parsec back on my work pc
my home my home pc rather and
let's go ahead and grab that
vfx materials
give it a moment here there we go i'm
going to copy this over
and we can go ahead and open it up
boom so you guys can see really again
parsec how awesome parsec
is um obviously i could have done this
here but if for whatever reason i had
files on that computer or i didn't have
something installed on my home computer
but
i do have it installed on the work
computer you guys really get the idea
um super super powerful so let's go and
edit let's
copy this no no let's copy the whole
plane and we'll go back into our
parallel dimensions project file we'll
paste
and we'll see if this actually works for
us
let's push this thing back and stand it
up
and we should have i don't know why i'm
not seeing it here but i should have a
fog layer
going
let's just go ahead and
really make sure we can see this fog
layer there it is
so we'll uncheck the camera
i'll hop out here and we'll push this
back right in here i'm gonna
scale it way up
and we'll stand it way up
so we're getting a lot of fireflies from
those
lights which is not ideal it's going to
take a long time to render
to get those fireflies away we can do a
couple things
first you can go to window i'm sorry go
to octane
octane settings and make sure your gi
clamp is set to one
if it is set to like a million
it's gonna look like that it's gonna
look insane so if your gi clamp is set
to one
you get rid of as many you get rid of
like the initial
chunk of fireflies i wouldn't go much
further
i think one is about as far as you'd
want to go
the second thing you could do is in the
octane camera tag if i'm in here
you got to make sure the check camera
option is on there's a highlight uh no
sorry under the camera imager tab you
scroll down
and there's a hot pixel removal if you
bring that
down it's going to get rid
of most of those fireflies
it's going to do a pretty good job of
that the last thing you can do
is make sure you have your spectral
denoiser turned on so it's denoising
those little bits and the more samples
you throw at this thing the faster it's
going to go
but that fog is too thick and this is
another thing that's going to help
let's just you know let's bring this
down a little bit
it's a little bit much
so we'll take this down to something
like that maybe
and we will bring this down
so you can see how that gets you a nice
little fog layer going
and then i'll copy it again
let's go into a top view
i'm going to ctrl drag this card back
behind
this light we had set up
to get us an even thicker
set of fog and i'll make sure it's
scaled up
and that's going to be a much faster way
to do fog
here in your scene we can even have some
foreground fog
so i can bring that card forward
basically right up to my character back
in top view
right in front of these huts right in
front
of that of that hut there that first one
and we're going to scale it way the heck
down
maybe that was too much what just
happened
yeah something like that and then we
could
you know take that and if the fog is too
thick we just bring the card down
because remember the top of the card is
um let's make that editable real quick
so we can adjust the gizmo by hitting l
and moving it
the top of the card is completely
transparent so we can have a nice
like low-lying fog and if we actually
crunch this down
like this we can have a nice little like
strip of fog that just hovers over the
ground like that
now you can really see um its
limitations here
because it's just like a cut-off point
it's a 2d fog we're faking it right so
this will work for the background i
think
for up to up to a certain amount
um but once it gets in the foreground
you can really tell it's like a veil
it's basically just a 2d veil
but again super quick little
little trick there to get yourself some
some foreground fog maybe some
background fog more
if we're being honest with ourselves um
so maybe i'll take those fog cards um
i'll make these all editable
all right maybe i'll just adjust the
adjust them a little bit
um we can make them all x-ray so we can
kind of see through
these cards
and again if you scale it down you kind
of
just get that half like low-lying fog
layer which can look really cool
so that's the big background one it
looks like the sun is
the mid ground fog layer
oh other way around
this guy
is our mid-ground fog
background fog and foreground
fog so we'll take the mid ground and
we'll crunch
it down
so you have that nice like low-lying
swampy fog layer that you know so you
can see like the tops of these guys
peeking out
that's super cool looking i dig that a
lot
sweet yeah and you can come in here and
definitely color correction is going to
help a lot because we're going to darken
this up and
really make it look nice and shape this
thing out
so i think now we're at a point where we
can start adding some like tree stumps
and stuff because this is looking pretty
freaking sweet
um now we still have the sky to do as
well
and the volcano smoke as far as the
volcano smoke goes
uh i don't know we'll have to see we'll
have to see about that
but for the sky i'm thinking about just
doing like a
basically a storm picture from google
and popping that into the background
there
basically just making it a background or
even you could do it in after effects
too
certainly possible let me let me take
these uh these
lights all of our
all of our hut lights i want to just
make them a little bit brighter
and you can actually make these hot
lights ooh
having them flicker a little bit would
be nice but that's
um
you know that's that's a different level
definitely a different level
um not quite sure how to do that i know
expresso can certainly do it
awesome looking super cool
very very nice i'm gonna do one last
little fog bit here
a little fog card cheat for the
background
so i want to do a
different material so i'm going to
duplicate the fog card
the material itself and i'm going to do
so black is foggy and i'm sorry black
is completely transparent
so i want to copy this so it's just
a strip of fog like that right
so we'll copy the background fog
and give it the new fog material
and i'll hop out of the camera just to
confirm that it's working
and i'll crunch it down move it up
and yeah you can see it's like a thin
layer of fog here
and that actually might be what we do
for the foreground
that way you won't see the actual uh the
gap
and i'm going to come into our top view
and let's move this
back up to the mountain so we have this
like
misty layer of fog right at the base of
the mountain
and i want to get that right so i'm
going to uncheck check camera
and we'll come into something
maybe it's like right right there
and i'll take that fog layer down
because i still want to see
the steam that we did in the in the
mountain
and maybe i'll try duplicating this
control drag
into our foreground because our
foreground fog you have that line
that harsh line
and we'll call this foreground we'll
call this uh
low lying fog
background and the foreground fog will
just bring right down to the floor
basically crunch it down
get it right onto the floor there
and we'll position it yeah just in front
there i think it might be a little too
subtle
so we'll adjust the gradient just to
come up a little bit
and there you can see you get that
low-lying foreground fog right there
we can bring this down
and you kind of hide the line there
you can crunch it down even more
and make it a little bit more subtle
so that's a easy and fast way to do fog
to cheat it
just a little something you know i think
that feels really good
so how's everybody doing are you guys
hanging in there are you doing all right
we got people coming in by the minute um
super super awesome
very exciting stream i'm having a blast
i love when
this stuff just comes together it looks
so nice
ah yeah absolutely amazing
ooh weedam perfectly centered renders
are not good renders
looks too generic my dude
um i hear you i hear you so
on that um i mean
centered style
framing is a choice a stylistic choice
i love it i really do love centered
framing um
i know what you mean by the generic
render though i definitely am not a fan
of like the generic render
definitely not a fan of that um
[Music]
and i i hear you you know they all
happen to be
kind of center framed i was definitely
not going for that
um certainly was not trying to go for
that look
but i do like you know in all of my
photography it is kind of that center
framed vibe so let me let me just show
you
give you an example um
so i do have a print store
shameless plug 50 off prints right now
um it's called noisegrainlight.com free
shipping over
orders uh 100 orders
even international but yeah i know i
mean
if you look at this horse you know we
got some center frame action we got some
center frame on this dude
um we got center frame with my buddy
young center frame with the basketball
um i'm a fan you know center frame with
my buddy adam again with shanghai
same here i always try to find something
and and frame it up
to the center you know i really i really
do enjoy that and i'm not always going
for that obviously
you know this building is framed
differently this one's framed
differently but
this fog foggy tree like if i'm finding
something like that i'm going with that
center frame
this is an example of a center frame but
it's off center because of this giant
fence
you know um center frame road
this one happens to be off center but
you got your tree your center frame tree
i'm a big fan of it um it's certainly
not what i'm always doing but like with
this one here you know you got to find
your subject
and get that center frame action it just
helps kind of tie the whole thing
together in my opinion
um you know this one here is a different
certainly different kind of framing
definitely center frame with the factory
with my buddy tom
[Music]
center frame here so i'm trying to find
that little element i do enjoy it but i
know what you mean man the generic
render
vibe is you know it's not the best vibe
i get it i certainly understand
but i'm hoping that you know when this
thing is done and comes together it's
it's not going to feel generic it's
going to feel it's going to feel special
you know and it's going to look
look nice so
another way to do fog actually guys is
with a z depth pass
so you know if i come in here like this
and we go to our render settings octane
render settings
info passes and we adjust the z depth
slider
you can actually use this as a fog
layer um
[Music]
inside of after effects you know it's a
really nice way to do that
and basically you would take this and
you know
set it to you can do it a number of
different ways you use it as an alpha
matte
luma mat um i feel like my distance
is too crunched here
so i might have to just do this in like
different little pieces
but it's certainly possible to do it
this way and that way you get rid
of the fireflies that you're seeing in
the background which
will plague a render it really will
so i might be doing it that way as well
most definite
dude yeah the center frame generic fps
shooter poster i
yeah exactly exactly
all right so i'm gonna parsec back into
my work computer
and let's go to bridge
and let's see let's see what we can find
here so
we've placed all of our structural
struct structural man
structural structural elements we've
placed all of them right
so i pulled um different
like trees and whatnot that i had
downloaded that i have downloaded
currently on my work computer
and we got some grass but let me just go
through and see
what we have here i'm going to reference
the my desktop
so we have a couple stumps we're going
to want
a few stump elements and we'll probably
want
a few uh like
you know burnt
down dead trees we're gonna want some of
that going on
and we'll put those off into the
background
and scatter them about
so that's what we're going to focus on
right now
so parsec into the work computer let's
figure out what we have
um let's do
where are we favorites 3d assets
we have mushrooms too so yeah i think
we'll get some of these fallen trees
we'll get some of these stumps
[Music]
now these guys these wooden branches i
think we can scatter
around the foreground um
definitely we'll definitely do that i'm
feeling that for sure but let's go ahead
and get
um a couple stumps placed
and then let's go ahead and get a couple
of the trees in the background place
because again we work from
from large scale to small scale so the
next thing up on the docket is the tree
stumps
all right so we'll do the tree stumps
and the burnt down trees
so parsec out of there boom
back to the work computer we know what
we want
so let's grab where are we favorites 3d
assets
this is a good stump this is a really
good broken stump so
i'm not going to go for the 8k texture
quite yet i'm gonna wait until i see
it's too low poly so i'll start with 4k
and i'll go for the level of detail
number
one um
we want to make sure we're export
settings
not download settings global export
settings
4k level of detail
number one
all right so let's export that guy it's
going to come into our scene
we're going for stumps and trees i like
this fallen tree
let's go ahead and export that guy this
dead tree
is definitely one that we are going to
need
um level of detail number one we don't
need to go super intense with it
how is this still how are these still
downloading
here's another like stump setup i like
that
let's go ahead and export that this is
another good stump
oh man man we got so many good stumps
y'all stump town up in here
this is probably the best stump of them
all king stomp
let's do that
i like this guy the mossy stump
sweet all right so let's see what we can
do we got that stuff coming in
my big old head is blocking the
materials coming in but you all gotta
trust
they're they're coming in you can see it
right here
they don't look good but we're gonna fix
that we're gonna make sure they do
ah eric okay you said you can do a
volume pass
in the image settings um what do you
mean man
let me know i want to learn uh
if you are not part of the discord
server
um it's the create with clint discord
server basically everyone here
is trying to learn got a whole server
you know to make it easy on y'all
go ahead and add me just send me a
message on that server
um and let me know what you mean by
that z depth pass because i definitely
need to find out the
easiest and fastest way to do the fog
and if you say there's a better way
i'm all ears my dude all ears i'm gonna
hide
these fog cards for now
um because
you know actually no i'm not gonna hide
the fog
cards i'm gonna just hide them from the
viewport
man it's looking good dude i'm it's
looking good
it's looking good i'm happy with this
all right so let's go ahead and check
the camera let's hop
out i'm going to save a new iteration
it's been a minute
version 1 l
and this is this is just because i'm
curious i want to see what this looks
like without
the color correction settings
much brighter that's the main thing it's
much brighter
god i can't wait i can't wait i can't
wait to color correct this thing man
it's gonna look so good
all right i'm hopping out and let's zoom
in
and adjust these stumpy stomps
so first let's figure out
what we have um well i'm going to
put the fog cards in their folder
and bring them down to geometry because
we want to stay as organized as we can
i usually go back and organize this
stuff when i'm done with the stream but
you know how it is boom let's let's
separate this stuff out we have a fallen
tree
asset right here it looks tiny
we're going to make it bigger we got a
stump we got some fur again stumptown
wood rot going
okay
we got some more stumps
um we got
is that king stump i think that's our
king stump
and that is just another old stump all
right so you can see they're much darker
so what i'm going to do is
go into these materials and make sure
they're set up properly so instead of
universal ggx i'm going to do
glossy octane
and you can see that kind of made things
a little
nicer so let me just
go down the line here and go glossy
and octane and that brightens them up a
little bit
right off the bat i think it looks a
little bit nicer and then we can adjust
from there
but we want our king stump
to be somewhere here in the foreground
in this little like swampy
area right in here so it's too dark
we'll have to adjust
its color settings but we'll do that
once we have it
placed or you know what
let's freaking do it right now because
we're here
and we can so let's go ahead and select
that guy we'll go into the node editor
and we have everything set up
qixel bridge makes it super easy on us
all right so we wanted to blend
into the ground itself so we'll just
need to adjust
the brightness and the gamma levels here
so just by tweaking the gamma
it already blends in i think i can take
the saturation down to 0.52
yikes just kidding let's try like .85
maybe
and that kind of gets rid of the green
that we're seeing
in there um maybe maybe we'll
we'll go point nine with it
because i think things could be a little
green in the swamp you know
it's possible
so that seems like the adjustment to be
honest with y'all like .61 on the
on the gamma maybe we could do like 0.7
but really not 0.6 was the vibe i think
that blends in really nicely
so i'm going to do that across the board
here i'm going to select
all of these different guys i'm going to
shift click
we'll go to the diffuse click in here to
color correction and we'll batch
do it by just going 0.6
and that's gonna you know kind of bring
in these guys
maybe we'll do 0.65
and we can do specific ones if we find
that they're too bright
i just want to blend them in with the
dirt really i just want to make them
feel muddy and gross
and we're kind of getting that by just
dropping the gamma they're going to be
off in the background too so it's not
going to be that big of a deal
but
we should at least kind of hone it in um
so gamma 0.65 let's do 0.8 for that one
and the saturation 0.85
cool and then we want to desaturate this
tree stump we can scale these up too
i'm definitely going to do that
sweet um and then lastly i'll just grab
this log
here
and i'll adjust the saturation
that feels pretty good to me cool so we
have our stumps
so we'll hop back into camera camera
mode i'm going to compare let's do i'm
sorry
options uncheck to check camera and
let's hop back
out and we'll start placing these so
king stump all right if we look at our
reference we got king stump right here
it's it's in the foreground
and it's it's looking nice it's right up
in your face
so let's get that going
right in here
now it's hovering right so we definitely
don't want that
so i want to get a good look at this
thing and just render that little piece
sweet yeah that looks great another
thing we can do
is go into that texture and make it a
little bit more
shiny right because it's in the mud so
it's wet
so we'll go in and this is going to be
i believe in our roughness we'll adjust
the roughness
so if i were to take maybe maybe i take
off the specular
that honestly kind of does it um if i
were to
get in here
go back to 0.5
you can see hopefully that there's a
sheen
on the other side of this thing
and that's because it just has a
roughness channel and no specular so
it's specular
is actually pretty bright so if i take
off the roughness
actually it got better with the
roughness
it is just going to be a bit more shiny
so i took off the specular channel
that's how i did that
so maybe i'd go on all of these guys we
go to specular
and we
let's see what's the best way to do this
because i don't want to delete it maybe
i'll just go through each one and
unhook each one so we still have it
there
we can grab it again if we need to
we'll hop back into the camera we'll
check the camera
go 1.2 again and maybe we make this tree
bigger
you know maybe we make this stump a
little larger
so i'm all for that let's let's give it
a shot
yeah that looks awesome
i think that totally works
we can get a stump here on the left as
well
maybe this guy right here
and we'll place we're gonna get the tree
further back that's that's gonna have a
place to go for sure we're gonna get
this guy in a nice
oh sorry this tree yeah this tree is
gonna be looking good
but this stump here
you know again again on orientation we
want to orient this
stump so that we it best describes its
features right so we can
scale it up
and push it down into
the ground there
something like that and it seems a
little bright to me
so i'm going to come back in here and
actually adjust
its gamma maybe point eight
or gamma one what does that look like
maybe go point nine on that guy
and we'll rotate it
that looks awesome i am a fan
certainly back to the reference um
we have this guy back here and we also
have this pretty big tree right in the
fort
right in like in its in his path so
i want to find a place for this guy
this big fallen tree i need to scale
this up certainly
and we can push this into the background
so that's a bit too apparent
i think what i might want to do is
actually have it
be here and we'll flip it around
and we'll just move it off to the side
let's clear this guy out
and make sure this guy is actually
completely in the ground
so i'm going to go 1.2
and we'll just render this region here
and take a close look to make sure it's
actually doing its job
perfect that looks really nice
i still think our king's thump can be
larger
and maybe we take
all of these huts
right in here
as well as the ground plane they're on
and hopefully the lights move with it
yep and i just want to push it off to
the right
a little bit
just a little bit because i want to make
a little bit more room for
this stump here um this guy can probably
come off
to the right maybe a little bit more in
the foreground
now i like it where it was
and then i'll grab these sticks and
maybe scale them up a little bit
i can't tell is that a
looks like a jacked up tree
then we got this guy to put somewhere we
can put this one maybe like
off over here
maybe it's just next to
next to this hut back here
we scale it way back up
again finding the right orientation that
best describes
its shape
and let's zoom in to see what it looks
like
we'll render the region
so there's a big hole on that side so
i'm going to flip it around
something like this
and push it down
not a fan of that i don't like that too
much
so i'm gonna go ahead and bring it back
into the foreground
that's not bad
it feels a bit too light to me so i'm
gonna
take the gamma
back to one
maybe even 1.2
and take the brightness down to 0.8
you just want to give this thing depth
you know
and then maybe we we go back on our
gamma
that's that feels pretty sweet to me
that feels really cool um
i might crunch the space here between
because i want to scoot this over a
little bit more
to make room for the stump just a bit so
i'm going to grab this hut
as well as this guy and
the land mass that they're both on
and just scoot them over to make a bit
more room
and i'll scoot the stump over just a bit
too this is all
composition we're talking right now is
getting the right composition
for your render
add our fog in
like this is really starting to take
shape here i
am a fan loving it
um random idea what if i took some
lights
if i made a light
angled it down negative 90.
adjusted the color temperature to 4200
and i put it underneath the huts
i wonder if it would give me a cool look
as if there's a hole underneath this
thing
and we'll make sure we don't want to see
the light rather we don't want to see
the light source so we'll turn it off
from camera
but it looks like it's giving us like a
really really intense
glare so let's take it down way down
let's take it down to like
a hundred or i'm sorry ten
it looks interesting um we can maybe
take it down to five
and i'll turn off the fog for a second
because it's taking a lot of
render juice
but that's interesting you know i'm not
uh not too opposed to that
i think it's just super subtle so it's
like shining through the floorboards
almost
i'm going to copy that to the other huts
to see
if we can get a cool look
this one will do two of them so i'll
push that down
and scoot this one over
yeah it gives it a little something it
actually gives it a little bit more
warmth
i like that a lot
i'm going to keep moving this over
and you can adjust the intensity of
those ones in the back if they're not
giving you enough
but i like that that's pretty subtle
and with the fog back on i think it
could actually look really really cool
so that's with our fog cards that we
created and this is with the volumetric
fog
as well
war climb yeah some candles and torches
could look sweet
certainly
maybe the uh the main guy here
has a torch or something
i think that could be cool so you just
need to watch out for these fireflies
with the fog
i think it's mostly the fog if i turned
off the the fog cards and the volumetric
fog
you're not really going to be seeing
those fireflies
oh you are a little bit here in the mud
so maybe we go back in that
in that layer and adjust its
specularity so i can come back let's see
here it's this guy we'll select our mid
ground we'll find
the material that makes it up
it's this mixed material so there's
something in this mixed material
um probably the specularity the super
height the super high specular detail
that we're not really getting out of
that
we can probably just uh adjust it and
knock that down a little bit we'd have
to make
a copy
of all of these different ones but i can
i'll just do that later i don't want to
bother y'all with that um next let's add
i'm going to parsec back in to my work
computer
all right so i'm at my computer in
downtown los angeles sitting in the
corridor studios
um and i want to find some
[Music]
tree assets i've already pulled them but
i just want to take a look here
um and show you guys
which ones we want to pull um we can do
the small sticks later
but i'm looking for like this stuff this
dead tree
yep okay
here we go these three basically these
three trees
these four right there we're going to
maybe even five
we're going to scatter with an octane
scatter around
our background
cool yeah so we'll grab those i'll
parsec back out
boom so now we know what we want
let's go ahead and all right those
these are still downloading i'm gonna
have to stop these i think
things just got a little out of control
perhaps
give the old refresh
all right so this dead tree yeah we got
this dead tree let's get this dead tree
it's a burnt one
we'll download that 8k obviously
but we only need to export the
the 4k maybe even the 2k
i'll go ahead and download that
so marthal arts you say rotoscoping is
super hard
um rotoscoping is tedious
and it could be hard because it's
tedious but i actually enjoy me some
rotoscoping believe it or not because
it's a chance for me to focus on just
one thing
and zone out on one thing um
there's different methods with
rotoscoping like you could use the
rotobrush
specifically rotobrush 2 is amazing
that's why i have after effects beta
installed here
which you guys can download if you go to
the
creative cloud um suite
little downloader and install at the far
left bottom there's there's beta you can
do after effects beta
um or you can do it by hand masking
which is
the most tedious hand masking is
certainly the most tedious you can do
luma mats as well
there's lots of different tricks for
rotoscoping and again if we're talking
general to specific
with rotoscoping it's the same thing you
start
on frame 0 you go to and then i
basically
i go every 10 frames and
roto every 10th frame and then i'll go
to the i'll go to the in between the
fifth frame
and i'll rotate those frames and
sometimes
i get lucky and you know
frame two three and four are done i
don't need to do a frame by frame
so you start general and you get more
specific more specific until you have
you know you do just amount
just the amount of work that you need to
do
all right
so we have one
two three we want to download this one
as
four
and i think there was a fifth tree in
here somewhere it was probably a stump
we can get this one as five
so we're going to download these and
we're going to use
octane scatter to scatter them around
our background once this guy's done
we'll go for it
juicy um i hope i said your name right
do you listen to music or podcast while
doing rotos since it doesn't require as
much thinking
um honestly dude even when i'm
rotoscoping i like to focus pretty hard
um but yeah i mean i'm listening to
music right now i got my bone phones on
i'm listening to the ambient playlist
um so yeah man i'll listen to some
ambient music while i'm going
certainly i'll try and listen to music
as much as i can
happy halloween to everybody who hasn't
heard it from me yet i am joseph seed
today if you cannot tell that's he's a
guy from far cry
um all right boom there's our fifth one
let's export these guys all 4k
i'm wondering though
can we get away with 2k
nah let's just do it
let's just freaking do it
brb
i lied i got some kombucha
i freaking love that stuff
freaking jeffrey dahmer's fashion
consultant
that's pretty good
all right two and a half hours in
i'm feeling good i think we're gonna get
these trees placed
and then i'd like to get a sky element
going
maybe place some sticks in the
foreground and i think we can call it
oh man so good
man i just feel like
i feel like getting healthier every day
with this stuff
oh ginger so good for you
all right y'all let's keep going oh man
we got some trees
let's do the same thing we did before
where we selected everything
and we said glossy octane
and they're gonna blend just a little
bit better
that's looking pretty good um we got
five trees let's go ahead and like open
this up so we can actually see what's
going on
now the trick here is to make it look
like
everything is actually like
we don't want it to look like it's
repeating this stuff is repeating
because this
this shape this silhouette is going to
get very noticeable
very quick so we have to be smart with
how much we move this stuff around okay
so here's what i'm gonna do i
want to
basically place these trees
along this area here
as well as this area here and i'm going
to do them separately okay so i'm going
to start with this one
which means we might have some trees
blocking this guy here
but we'll figure it out i don't want too
many of them that's for sure
and i know that we'll be able to
see the trees a bit more clearly with
the fog layers on so i'm going to turn
on our fog
cards
in order to see those trees just a
little bit more
and let's do
um yeah let's let's go for it so i'm
going to make an octane scatter
object here you can find that by going
to objects octane scatter it's right in
there
or hit shift c and
octane scatter boom right there
so the idea is that you have this octane
scatter and it's
asking what do you want me to scatter
what objects you want me to scatter in
this case will be our trees
and where do you want me to scatter it
across what surface
and that's the same with any scatter
object you use whether it's like a
cinema 4d
you know object cloner or whatnot
it's the same deal so the first thing i
do is i want to tell
it where it should scatter the objects
to or across in this case it is this
little area here
which is uh our lake
so we can literally just type in lake um
across the surface of no we can't type
it in that'd be sweet though
we have to drag and drop boom so it's
going to be scattering stuff across the
lake you can see
here that we have all these little
points and it's on the vertex
of our lake we don't want vertex we want
across the surface
so that will randomly scatter all these
different little pieces across the
surface of our lake
now there's too many definitely there's
too many i can see just by looking at
these green dots
so i'm going to take the count down to
100 just a simple
100 trees scattered across our lake
okay we can go to display
and we can say they are boxes
instead of lines which
that's not updating
circles
whatever we'll go with line we'll stick
with line keep it simple
the idea is that we want to take all
five of these trees and we want to make
sure the gizmo is at the very bottom
of these things because it's gonna it'll
spawn it
that's perfect yep
that is a little low so we want to bring
this one up
this one is a little low as well we can
bring this up too
and you can hit s to snap to your object
you have selected
that's actually fine and that is
fine so we'll grab those
we'll put them in the octane scatter
and you can see in our render we have
trees
coming out of the lake which looks super
cool
so you have some options on how these
things are actually scattered around
first it's doing it's scattering all
these objects
equally so if we want to
scatter one object more than another
we'll want to duplicate
it in the actual in the subfolder here
so
i actually want this tree let's see if
we can zoom in here
and we actually need to move our five
original objects away
we just need to move them out here
because
they're going to be in our scene we
don't want that we don't want to see
them
so this guy here i'll duplicate that
and this guy here i'll duplicate that
just holding ctrl and dragging
and that's going to give us more of
those than we'll see of these guys
you know because we want more of the
actual trees themselves than we do the
stumps
so you can see the black lines are the
taller trees
now one big thing that we need to do
here is
let's take a look technically we might
have some trees going through our huts
but
i don't in this case i think we're good
so what we can do we need to randomly
rotate all of these trees otherwise
they're going to look like
obvious copies we can also set the count
up to like 200
to give it a little bit more something
back there
so rotation you know you could do it all
through here
but i found the easiest way for me is to
do it with uh
the cinema 4d modifiers so we'll go
into here we'll grab a random modifier
and we'll or i'm sorry it's an effector
and
we'll just drag and drop it into the
effectors tab
in the octane scatter object
so now what it's doing is it's moving
all these pieces around we're saying the
position we want to randomly
um you know organize or randomly
organize we want to randomly scatter
the position x y and z we don't want
them floating so i'm going to take y to
zero
but this x and z is totally fine it's
just moving them like around this
surface we can see all of our trees
and then we want rotation this is the
big one we want to rotate our trees
so that they don't they're not all lined
up so let me
hop back in here
and let's see if we can see this
you can see how our trees are
basically kind of lined up in the same
way
this little black piece this black piece
so we want to organize that we want to
rotate that around
so we could give it a little bit of
you know rotation on that axis
a little bit on that axis so they're
kind of tilting
you know maybe 30 degrees on each
but really it's this one here oh sorry
hold on
i got these mixed up let's do this the
right way first
all right this is the one so
notice these two trees how they look the
same if i set that to
um 360 they're going to be randomly
spun around and they actually look the
same there so let me try
1080 and they still look the same
let me try 180.
i believe they look different now
yeah they look different now and then
i'll give it 30 degrees
and 30 degrees so maybe
maybe 15 and 15. so they're all kind of
just randomly
oriented like that we can also do scale
so i'll come in here to scale and i just
want to give it a little something so
it just breaks it up a little bit more
uniform and absolute we can say 0.5
maybe even one so some of them are
scaled up
and some of them are scaled down
and maybe it's 0.8
we'll hop back into our camera
and it's too many trees way too many
trees
um so let's check the camera and hop out
and it's coming into our foreground here
we don't want that
so what we could do
is just adjust the seed maybe take the
count down until we get something that
looks right so maybe we do
100 maybe that was right you know the
first time we did it
versus 200.
i'm just going to re-render here to make
sure this is updating properly
uh
and we still have trees up in our hut so
we don't
we don't want that
so i'll set the count to 100 and i'm
just going to adjust the seed
until we get something that works so
the seed is set to ten thousand i'll
just keep adjusting that
maybe we'll do 70 trees
and let's bring our other fog layer in
because it looks like there's too many
but i think with the other fog
layer it'll they'll kind of be hidden
and going back to our reference there's
not too many trees here
there's a few so
maybe we take it to 50.
and i think there's too many stumps i
think we need
just
we could probably get rid of
of this guy at least
and it still looks too uniform
and i think i need a bit more
of fog between this little layer here so
i'll use the fog card to really shape
that
the the foreground fog card yeah that's
one that
that we can use so i'll control drag
this back
and that feels better that certainly
feels better um but i want to keep
adjusting the seed because i don't like
how there's just like four of the same
thing here
and i'm also going to take the random
and i'm going to go
1080 on the rotation the random rotation
i'm just gonna randomly
throw it off in any direction um and
then
we'll take the scatter take the seed to
like two
and we'll keep going until we find
something that works for us and we'll
render region
across this bit here
so 2 isn't bad
but three is uh three's pretty nice
i like that
so it's really just like trying to find
the look now these guys are coming out
from under the ground
obviously four doesn't work
and five we have a duplicate kind of a
look here which i'm not a fan of
so far three has been the one
oh eight eight could be
a winner
i like eight
so they're coming like they're too you
know close to the foreground we can
obviously like
find a different plane that these things
can um
can sit in
14 15. yeah we'd probably be better off
scattering them across something
let's go ahead and let's try this let's
duplicate the lake
control yep and then i'm going to hide
it
from everything except i'm sorry except
for the viewport
and i'm gonna just choke this
up and push it back
so they're not gonna be
really in the way of our foreground
they're just going to kind of be in the
background
and i'm going to say lake dot one is
what we're scattering across
lake so now we'll get more of our trees
in the area where we want them
and i think we can get to something that
we like a little bit faster
and this is just you know going through
and finding that that right
look you know
but i think you guys get the idea i
think that's starting to feel uh
feel pretty nice here
and you could definitely take this fog
card
and duplicate it and push it back to
keep giving you more
depth on the the tree layers you know
so that's really going to help us
get depth in those trees
and you could certainly overdo the fog
so just be careful
but i am i'm feeling something like this
guys i think this is
this is looking good
fantastic so the last thing i want to do
is i want to find a sky that looks good
for us
that i can put into the background here
so i'm going to parsec back into
my work computer in downtown l.a
and if you guys are just joining me here
um
parsec is the sponsor of today's stream
it's
a remote desktop application and
it's it has basically zero latency very
low latency
it gets you two monitors you're able to
do two monitors with parsec warp
so you got your second monitor popping
up here boom second screen
this will be over on my other screen
here
it also allows for tablet support so any
like pressure sensitive
tilt sensitive stuff i'm always on my
tablet so
they actually came out with parsec warp
which is a service that supports
the tablet i freaking love it and it
also has a perfect
444 color mode which basically means
that for every pixel on your monitor you
have a specific color
and you can you know toggle that on here
preferred 444 you got your second screen
you can use this to play video games i'm
gonna be using this when i'm in georgia
and i'm uh you know trying to get some
renders out and i just have my laptop
i can parsec into my home computer here
and get a really nice
look um be able to use this whole
freaking workstation
from uh wherever you're at you can be at
a coffee shop it doesn't matter
but we've been doing it uh yeah yeah
yeah
it's helped me so much with uh with
quarantine
because we've been parsecking into our
work computers at corridor
at the beginning of all this actually up
until like last week
and have been able to get work done that
way so i'm in my
actual corridor computer right now
parsec dan
and i want to find some awesome
uh some sky pictures that i think will
will look good for our background so
here's what i'm gonna do
i am let's open this window up here
let's do
boom all right so this is what we're
looking for for our swamps
um
let's go ahead and type in like storm
clouds
and we'll go tools size
we'll go large
and see what we can find here
so you want to find something like i
mean this could be interesting
but that i believe let's see if we can
do
in google we'll go
settings search settings
um
uh ah maybe settings advanced search
for the let's see there's a size image
size we can go
we can choose the size we want
so we can say 8 megapixels
for our storm clouds and we'll do an
advanced search for that and then we'll
get these
images here that are at least 8
megapixels
so you want to find something that looks
freaking awesome you know like we want
to go for something like this so it's
definitely some storm cloud vibes with
maybe like a little sun
sunrise in the back okay so we can pull
some of these and just figure out like
what the heck works
maybe this guy
and technically you know we're
ripping images here um definitely don't
use this for the wrong reasons
if you're gonna do something that is
like
for commercial or whatever um
you definitely need to get the correct
rights for these you know
so just be careful when you're all doing
this
storm clouds
ooh ooh
that is nice all right so here in case
this is a freaking crazy
um
yeah in case this is a crazy ad i am
gonna just
download this on the other window just
in case
second screen
let's see what happens
this is a 15 second download it's gonna
take a minute huh
so i think that's gonna be the easiest
way for me to do this is to actually
have it
um with a with an image versus
you know like a whole cloud volume
system
hey it worked okay desktop boom
and i'll find like one more
one more image here that we can use
um
oh this could be interesting
try this one
because i again i do want to have like a
vibe where the sunlight kind of shines
through and hits the mid ground area i
think that could look
really really nice
so i'll try those two
maybe those three and
i'll put them in the correct folder here
vfx materials i'll disconnect from
parsec
and i'm back into my home computer
and let's see let's go and grab those
[Music]
you can't get parsec working for some
reason on your network
um i mean definitely reach out to
to the guys at parsec they're super
super easy to get in touch with
they're very very kind and see if they
can't help you out
if you message me on discord
there's a link to my discord in the
description below
if you go ahead and message me there i
can make sure that
we find guys to help you out with that
okay
all right so yeah let me grab these
images here yeah there's those fireflies
we've got got to get those
out of there somehow some way
but let's go ahead and hide the fog it's
all coming from the fog that's like
that's the whole
reason we're getting the fireflies
all right and let's go ahead and grab
those images we just pulled
copy them over
all right so the best way to
do this might
be with a background
so i'm going to save a new iteration
so i can always take account of
you know all my different versions here
i can render this out
man this is freaking awesome i'm on a
quadro card right now and i'm just super
impressed with like
i'm able to just go through this without
any issues
i've only used five gigs of vram of the
24 gigs of vram available
pretty incredible pretty pretty
incredible
heck i'm going to throw another fog card
into this background let's go background
fog card
i want to see it in my
viewport
i'm going to control drag this guy all
the way back
all the way back
and i'll scale it way the heck up and
just
get some separation on these mountains
here
that's nice
awesome all right
so let's see if we can get this
background going
i'm going to make
a background which is the background
and see if
this doesn't work i could always do it
with a card
but let's let's just see if this works
i'm gonna make an
octane diffuse material i'm gonna hop in
here
and boom we'll throw an image texture in
and it's going to be
one of these let's start with let's
start with this one i think it's a
different look that i think could be
really cool
i'm gonna give it projection um we'll do
box projection so the ratio of the
images maintained
and we'll give it a transform so
we're able to adjust its
size and let's pop that onto the
background and see what the heck we get
nothing's coming through because our
environment is shining through
so if i do octane settings
and i scroll down let me open up the
alpha channel
now we want the background to actually
shine through
and reflect into our foreground so
that's actually
not i don't think it's going to work
if we do it this way so maybe we take
the background away
and we do it with a card so let's make a
plane
and scale it way back up
move it back
rotate it upright holding shift to snap
at the 90 degree increments and we'll
open it up
and i just want to check the aspect
ratio
oh i want to check the aspect ratio of
this image
right here because i want to maintain
the aspect ratio
so it is
1919 by 1279.
but hold on we don't need to do that
because
we made it a box projection so
no worries and we'll turn it around
180
whoa
maybe we do need
mess uv
1919 by
1279 was that it
19 yikes 1919
times 100
12 79
1279 times 100
so that should be maintained
that looks like absolute but
absolute but we got those rings in there
which i have no idea why that's the case
um it looks like it needs
well you know maybe what we could do is
actually just make a normal c4d material
give it that image
copy the path i'm going to color
no it's a luminance luminance just makes
it a see-through basically just we see
the image
and we'll go ahead and paste
yikes grab that nope
apply the new material and hopefully
let's try and re-render the scene it
should shine through as just the normal
image
all right
interesting why is it just black
maybe it needs the now the luminance
should do the trick
maybe because it's not octane um but
octane is going to make it an emissive
this should be really easy i don't know
why this isn't working
now does anyone know how to make this
thing double-sided
um because this should
be showing the image
both sides are not
i wonder nope
hmm
oh i know why it's probably because it
needs to be emitting like
freaking a thousand
see that just looks horrible though
yeah not having the best luck here
with this technique i feel like it'd be
the way to go though
it's certainly like the way to go in
theory
it might just be something we have to do
in after effects
we're getting some weird artifacts here
it's very dim
[Music]
it's not working properly i think the
emission
needs to be boosted
but that just looks horrible that looks
absolutely horrible
this might be one for another time i'd
have to figure this one out
because we want to get something like
like this you know and the birds
the birds i'm probably gonna do in after
effects i actually
filmed some birds against the sky and
i'll just you know
luma mat them out key them out and pop
them into my scene
it's probably the best way to go about
it
um but man like other than that like i
definitely need to get the sky
i need to get the birds um i need to
the next biggest thing is my character
model
i'm going to photo scan myself in like
my camping gear basically
and apply me to the character
and have me walking towards this
mountain in the background
i mean no one's going to know it's me
but it'll be me
you know it'll it'll be pretty sweet
it'll be pretty sweet
so you know maybe actually here
to give you guys an example of what
we'll do i'm going to open up after
effects
and i'll show you what we can do here
with the sky because it's as simple as
here let's just turn on our fog
let's
turn back on the alpha
and we'll drop a sky in the background
here
and you'll see what i mean
so i'm gonna let this uh render
here
1920x810 awesome
yeah an hdr image would probably work
something from like uh
hdri haven they have the highest quality
hdris
that'll probably be the best way to go
it's not going to help me too much on
render time but hopefully i can get
a super high res render out in like a
day if i just freaking render
all day long on this
but let's go ahead and file we'll save
this as a png
um we'll go versions and we'll just call
this i don't know
sky alpha
and we'll hop into after effects and
i'll bring that in
and we'll bring in those cloud
images and see what we can do i just
want to see if this will work
see how these look so we'll bring those
in
and we'll bring in
this version here look how far we've
come
so we started like this and
now now we're here
uh now it's like this you know so we're
certainly
coming a long way
i'm loving it okay so let's drop this in
and let's drop in some of these skies
and see what we can do
obviously i got to get my denoiser going
it's a little sparkly
but i mean this this could look pretty
freaking sweet right here
we just have to blew it up you know a
little bit of levels on that
go with a little bit of blue uh
where are you at
now also what we could do is uh
is we could grab this render
and sample this sky color
drop it underneath
and lower the opacity
you know so something like that and we
can duplicate that layer
bring it on top and
we can use extract so if i bring this up
i can use extract
to cut out all of the
the dark bits of the clouds
and then soften it and cut back in
something like that so now it's over top
of everything obviously we don't want it
over our huts
so i'm going to just do a big old mask
around
yikes do a big old mask
around that and we'll just
hit we'll subtract it hit f
for feather feather the crap out of it
let's just get it to get us an idea of
feeling
i'll hit t and we'll go
35 opacity and 35
opacity there so you have a little bit
of like the foreground
clouds coming in just a bit um we can
definitely take both of those we'll
parent
both of them together so now we move
them together
we have a little bit of like foreground
cloud action
so that's certainly one way we can do
this if we
invert that let me try
invert we can get a different look
different kind of cloud look or we could
simply let's do
can darken it up a little bit or
something so that could be a cool way to
do
the sky um let's try that
sunrise one
so this one here
something like that could be pretty
sweet
i'm a big fan of like the foreground
being stormy and the background being
uh you know basically sunlight
or sunset or something or the opposite
where
the foreground is sunny but the
background is is dark
i like that a lot
so we could do something like that and
again we could lower the opacity of it
to bring in back some of the original
sky
so just to give us some options here i
think this technique could work if it
blended with the mountain a little bit
better and
the fog layers could blend a little bit
better but i think that's not bad at all
um i mean heck we're here
we could try some some color correction
to see what this would look like if i
just kind of
gave it a bit of
[Music]
contrast
maybe some darker shadows
and a a legit vignette
so i have a little vignette element that
i use all the time
which i mean you could you can honestly
do this in in after effects super easy
just make a black solid
ctrl y for that double click your
ellipse tool
and it'll perfectly do it we'll subtract
it
f for feather feather the crap out of it
and that's too intense but i'll change
it to overlay
so the highlights will come through the
vignette and then you just take that
down to like 50 percent
and you get something something pretty
nice um
take the adjustment layer maybe bring
the shadows we'll go back up to zero on
that
so it gets you something something nice
there
and yeah i mean you could do the same
thing actually if you want to have a
little bit of reflection in your
foreground
you could take your storm clouds ctrl d
to duplicate
w to flip
up side down
holding shift to snap
come on bud
holding shift to snap this into place
we'll bring it up top
and basically
if you let's see grab our foreground
duplicate it solo it so we're only here
and then i'm going to do an extract as
well
we'll extract the bright parts out
and feather that bring it down
and we just want
let's see
put that above our storm clouds and you
can kind of see how you get like some
reflection
on the ground here from these storm
clouds you could take it down to like
50 percent that way you still maintain
some of the original
but i mean that that could look pretty
sweet you know
pretty cool
yeah but i think from this point it's
just you know
getting the uh the mountain to look a
little bit
more blended into the environment having
clouds be around the mountain
like this versus like this so we just
need like
you know some stuff coming out the top
of the mountain some smoke and whatnot
but
i think this is looking pretty cool this
gives me an idea of where i'm going to
go
for my final look um
so i'm going to delete all that boom
don't even care don't even care
and the fireflies we definitely need to
get rid of those so
i reached out to someone here saying to
hit me up on discord
i'm looking out for you i want that z
depth technique if you got it
i am all ears
but guys that's uh
that's about it i mean i'm very very
very happy
with what we have here i think it looks
fantastic
um it's just gonna take maybe another
day or so
for me to really hone this in to bring
it in
um i'll probably use an hdri for the
background i think it's probably the
best
bet probably do some hdri haven
um maybe scatter some sticks along the
ground definitely change out the
character that's
certain and yeah you guys have the
extension if you're
submitting uh in this render contest and
the parallel dimensions render contest
then you have until november 6th the
link to submit
is down below in the description
um yeah keep at it the top 20 winners
i'm going to choose
on november 7th next week i choose all
the winners i go through all the
submissions
and i choose the top 20 best ones i'm
going to put them together into a sweet
audio visual montage
so definitely you know bust out a render
super cool uh
render just like this you can download
the template on the landing page it's
the same link that you go to submit
your uh your render and join the contest
we got blender links in there or blender
files we got cinema 4d files we got an
fbx
so i'm expecting some cool renders from
y'all and i've seen some cool ones so
far too
pny is putting out an article on this
whole process
next week and they have
some renders that i actually want to
show you guys that have come in from the
community that i think are super cool
um yeah the due date was november 2nd
but it got pushed in november 6th
so you guys have time you have until i
believe friday
there is a countdown timer on the pny
website
so don't miss it definitely don't miss
it i'm excited to see all of your guys's
renders
i'm excited to get rid of these
fireflies in my render it's the freaking
fog dude it's the fog
killing me and yes
it is halloween so i'm joseph seed um
this halloween i got my gray jacket
right here it's no suit jacket but
a little something
chris yay dude um thanks for stopping by
i'm glad it was your first stream i'm
glad it's not the last stream i'll see
you on discord buddy
um heck yeah
good times y'all good times
i'm excited to see your render and again
thanks to
our buds over at parsec for sponsoring
this thing let me parsec back in one
more time
just for the love of it it's so quick
and so fast to hop in here and i'm
literally on
my computer at corridor right now
i'm at home but i'm on my corridor
computer through parsec
uh it's a super fast super easy
remote desktop application if you guys
want to check out parsec
it's actually free if you want to check
it out but they do
have parsec warp which gives you the
extra added benefits
like the dual screen the second screen
which you can pop over to the right
side it's got you with tablet support
and a in a 444 color mode
i think you save 20 percent if you sign
up for a year
parsec warp give it a shot it's a blast
you can play video games you can do
whatever the heck you know when you go
away for christmas or thanksgiving bring
your laptop and
parsec into your main desktop i promise
you you won't be
you won't be disappointed it's a good
time
but y'all happy halloween be safe
have fun don't eat too much candy brush
your teeth
all right and uh i'll see you guys
on the discord server create with clint
discord server
it's been a good time sodamonte thank
you
for moderating uh the chat here
and thanks for moderating the server you
all are the best i'll catch y'all
very very soon i'm a chill for the next
uh
two minutes here i'm gonna take a little
break i'm gonna come back
answer any questions you all might have
and i'm gonna sign off okay
um so i will
be back in two seconds see you guys soon
and we're back
we're back
all right
all right where are you all at you all
got questions what kind of questions you
guys have
let's see let's find out
all right
can you add sound effects to your
submission you can do whatever the heck
you want to your submission
i just wouldn't um
i'm going to cut your sound effects
probably because not all of them are
gonna have sound effects and i'm gonna
add
music to it um it would be cool if they
all had sound effects but
the plan is to have music i'm not gonna
stop you from adding
uh sound effects i think it could be
cool and it would add an extra element
so i might find a way to incorporate it
christian have i got around to playing
some desk draining absolutely dude
um i have yet to beat the game i'm gonna
beat the game
my goal this year is to beat uh last of
us two which i did it was amazing
um goes to tsushima with some which i'm
almost done with i love it
and death training so i'm definitely
getting some destroying vibes
with this uh with this art and there's
your ghost of tsushima
you know right in here you definitely
have a lot of these kind of buildings in
that game
and um it has death straining vibes too
at the same time
it's like a combination of all three
games that have been playing
which i think is pretty sweet
visual yes dude i'm so glad that you're
glad that we have an extension because
you put out some of the best stuff i'm
so glad
that you're gonna freaking crank on this
thing and make it awesome
the top 20 is i mean dude
you win the render contests a whole lot
so
i'd be surprised if you didn't make top
20 dude
all right what else what else kind of
questions we got
can you displace the mountain a bit i
want to add a little snow layer
yeah you can do it man you can do it
just a little bit snow layer i think
would be awesome
yeah as long as you don't change the
overall like vibe of the mountain too
much
and when i say vibe i mean silhouette as
long as you don't mess with the
silhouette of the mountain and change it
completely
then you're fine you know it's totally
cool to add a snow layer
and texture it how you want
all right
yup in today's corridor episode there is
a teaser for birdemic we're redoing the
birds for birdemic
i spent actually let me show you
um so i'm parsect in to my work computer
i'll show you this bird sim that i've
been going burdemic remake
let me give you guys a little little
tease
let's see renders
where are we at where we have vfx
renders
so this is a shot that i worked on
oh yes unknown file oh because i try to
open it that's why
two seconds
let me let me show you guys this bird
nemac nonsense
so i had to get oh actually no it's my
v2 the v2 version is tracked a little
bit better
so i had to rig up this eagle
which i also downloaded downloaded from
turbosquid and
ren 3d tracked the scene and i came up
with a
particle uh particle simulation like a
particle system
with x particles getting these birds
flying around all right
and then you guys saw i think
this one here which is a shot peter did
which is absolutely incredible
so good so i'm excited this is gonna be
really stupid
really really dumb but uh i hope you
guys
i hope you guys enjoy that it's gonna be
a good time
all right what else we got what else we
got questions happy halloween to y'all
uh does parsec need fast internet speeds
i only have 40
um megabytes and when i use chrome
remote for c4d
use at school i get low frame rates um
zspc definitely give it a shot you know
you can download parsec for free
see what you can see and i mean
it works for me most certainly and yes
xp flock that is
exactly what i'm using
absolutely
but yeah guys i think that's about it um
yeah peter's freaking nuts he's really
great
he's a freaking beast a blender
beast the dude is crazy and he's so
young too
but all right y'all i think it's time
i'm gonna sign off thanks for sticking
in to the end guys happy halloween
stay safe and i'll see you guys on the
discord server november 6th
get your renders in because i'm going
over
all of them and i'm choosing the top 20
and choosing the top
three winners on november 7th the day
after alright guys
so be safe see you guys later peace out
good times happy halloween don't get too
scared
bye